[Aplausos]
puede parecer sorprendente pero estas
imágenes han sido tomadas a finales de
marzo de este año
si no se adormeció una sensación de
complacencia porque las diversas medidas
de la pandemia ya sea el recuento diario
de casos o el recuento de muertes o
incluso las tasas de positividad de las
pruebas comenzaron a disminuir a partir
de octubre y a principios de enero se
redujo a niveles bajos
[Música]
y luego estaba este sentimiento
propagado incluso por expertos de que en
realidad habíamos alcanzado la inmunidad
colectiva
sin embargo sucedió lo indeseado india
es el segundo país más poblado del mundo
y cuenta con más de 1300 millones de
habitantes el doble de la población
latinoamericana todo indica que la
creciente de contagios ha sido
consecuencia de una gran densidad pero
también de las manifestaciones
multitudinarias y festivales religiosos
donde se hicieron millones de personas
además de las campañas realizadas para
las elecciones de bengala occidental
y la inhabilidad de seguir los
protocolos de salubridad
estas libertades han sido respaldadas
por el gobierno
me radio sevilla no doctor hugo tenemos
que evitar que nuestro país entre en
cuarentena invitó a los gobiernos
estatales que consideren la cuarentena
como última opción lockdown se va
tenemos que esforzarnos por escapar de
una cuarentena y centrarnos en zonas de
micro contención micro canten men jon
pared de handy arma esto ha traído
consigo trágicas consecuencias cada vez
hay más decesos y los hospitales han
colapsado el país atraviesa escasez de
oxígeno y algunas víctimas mortales
arden en fuego en ciudades como varanasi
al orilla del río ganges
habrá que esperar para conocer las
nuevas medidas adoptadas por el gobierno
indio